peace I'm common and I'm here to do a
Google autocomplete interview we're good
to go it's coming bad at anything yes
I'm bad in a lot of things I'm
definitely not a good cook I actually
don't know how to cut hair even though I
looked like I knew how to cut hair and
barber shop
what else can I can't play chess really
good and I'm not a good liar I probably
got some a lot more things I could tell
you about but we got more more questions
it's common going for the e god yes
I am going for the e god that's a great
question because I'm going to put that
out there in the atmosphere first of all
I'm super grateful to have a oscar award
and a grammy award but it would be
incredible for me to achieve him an Emmy
Award and a Tony Award and I'm going for
it it's coming from the Midwest yes I'm
from Chicago Illinois born and raised
barber shop the next cut takes place in
Chicago so I'm very happy to be a part
of that because one of the first films
that I got to be a part of there
represents where I'm from so yeah I'm
from the shot what is Commons biggest
annoyance to be honest my biggest
annoyances when people have a job and
they don't know how to do the job well
that's annoying to me what is Commons
favorite food I would say it's between
pizza and I love french fries
so those probably would be two of my
favorite foods and popcorn popcorn is
something that I really love what is
Commons charity named it's called the
common ground foundation if you want to
support go check out common ground
foundation org and I'm spreading some
love where did where they come and get
his name it's funny talking about myself
in third person I actually chose my name
I was at college my mother used to
always say use common sense use common
sense one day I was just sitting around
I was trying to think of a name and my
friends was smoking something that they
costs NT but
is a form of weed for some reason the
name common sense just came up to me I
was like that'd be a dope rap name so
really my name was common sense and then
it was a group that had the name so I
had to shorten it to comments at first I
was real pissed off about it because
they the group had the name and I had
already come out with two albums but now
I'm happy because people I feel like I'm
the everyday people's artist so common
fits where they come and have his first
job well my first job was like doing
janitorial work at this nursery school I
had to clean up mornings before I went
to school and then clean up some at
night after school and my last job since
I've been an artist was I used to sort
out parking tickets from the city and I
was a terrible job that was one of the
things that made me be like man I wanna
I gotta go pursue my dream because I
didn't want to do sorting out parking
tickets don't sound good do it even on
camera guys shaking his head where
they're coming first meet President
Obama one of my first conversations was
at this parade in Chicago called the bud
Billiken parade this was around 2006 in
fact one of my albums had just come out
he told me he just bought the album so
that's when I first got a chance to
really build with the president you
always been cool ever since I love them
that's why I first met the president